okay guys i just got back from the
premiere of 300
rise of an empire and i had to talk
about this film immediately
so get ready to get horny watching this
movie critic do a review cause you're
gonna be watching me for a few minutes
why wouldn't you get horny
300 rise of an empire this looked like i
was doing a [ __ ] thing
this film is pretty freaking badass
and at one point you see sullivan
staples ass from the side he's got a
pretty bad ass too if you know what i
mean i'm not just saying that because i
went to the premiere i'm not kissing ass
here
i'm not an ass kisser but occasionally
i am a dick sucker it does have more
story in it it does have more character
part of what makes these movies so
[ __ ] cool
is the visual experience itself it's
supposed to be telling the story
through the visual experience think
about it because the narrator is like
telling a
tale kind of has a fairy tale about a
fairy tale that's what the kids used to
call me in school
i had a tail fairy too look at me now
[ __ ]
i'm on youtube you know how hard it is
to upload a video it takes time
right off the bat i think the first
thing you're going to notice is just how
much more ridiculously violent this film
is
compared to the first one like everyone
is just fighting just chopping off each
other's limbs and i say that
take it real literal it's not just
slashes people's
body parts are just flying and it's in
slow motion and it's crazy
blood everywhere i started laughing at
just how much there was
the whole time i was like [ __ ] damn oh
[ __ ]
hot pot of coffee you feel like that at
any moment someone even one of the main
characters is just gonna get chopped up
into pieces
and the blood is like it's totally cgi
so it's not like disturbingly violent
it's fun it's badass i like how the
director
took inspiration from zack slander's
original direction but i feel that he
added his own flair to it it didn't feel
like the first one sure visuals are
similar it's significantly darker you
know the
secret ingredients any reboot remake or
sequel just go
darker that's why when chocolate
rebooted themselves
they got dark chocolate
god no please stop laughing it's okay
people it's like
it's okay and i saw this in imax 3d and
if you know me
i love imax imax is awesome and this
film is one hell of an imax experience
imax and i have a special relationship
i'm max and i hang out sometimes
sometimes i make some
you know am i full of mine a little bit
little little there
a little hill there it's nothing serious
though you know but i am starting to
develop feelings for him yes i max is a
guy it's not gay it's just fun i saw the
first one on imax and i can honestly
tell you
this one is a better experience the 3d
was top [ __ ] notch you
feel like there is blood just squirting
on you you're like
period menstrual cycle stop stop no no
you're being too kind stop god
ah it's like being on the lettermanship
i mean just the cinematography
alone is awesome the only times when i
was a little bored was when like it
started actually feeling like a retread
of the first one like when the main
character
the mcleodless or whatever the [ __ ]
guy's name is he
would give speeches and i'm like okay no
leonidas but he's giving a [ __ ]
speech but look we go to this film for
the action we go to it for the visuals
so when you go when they're wanting that
they under promise and they over deliver
you walk out wanting to kick some ass
i beat up so many people after this
movie was done
i even bought a sword at the man's
chinese theater and i just started
slashing up people the athenians
they mainly feel like just men they're
they're not you know a bunch of
trained warriors a lot of them are just
you know like oh he's a
blacksmith or something i don't know
what the [ __ ] kind of jobs people have
back then so in a way it does add more
attention to it because unlike the first
300 it was like ah
the spartans are gonna be fine until the
end when they all die
but like having the combination of the
athenians being mainly just
regular men who happen to be really cut
like the majority of mark wahlberg's
roles and then added with the non-stop
violence
it just makes you feel like any of these
characters could just die suddenly
sullivan staples as themos galileosus
female stroke the mastodos
never remember who the [ __ ] this guy was
called in the movie anyway he's uh he's
he's basically
gerard butler's replacement you know
he's not playing leonidas or anything
but you know he's he's the one who's
supposed to be like the follow-up dude
from leonidas i mean yeah he's good in
the role he's likable he's
passable he's charming but you know
gerard butler was like a
strong presence where like everything
you said became a [ __ ] quote
this guy is kind of just a normal dude
but you know who [ __ ]
rocked it this time around it might not
have been the lead but it was a [ __ ]
villain eva green as artemis gordon
as artemisia artemis gordon is kevin
kline's character from wild wild west
classic she is sexy she is scary she is
the ultimate badass chica [ __ ]
i love female characters that are
villainous skilled
warriors and don't put on like some
[ __ ] oh
i'm evil performance like she's a scary
ass [ __ ]
at one point she slices the guy's throat
takes that same knife slices the back of
his neck
pulls off his head and then just starts
making out with a decapitated head that
was a decapitated head that'd totally
make out with her i don't get why she
did it but for some reason it just works
for the character there's this sex scene
that
everyone's talking about it's a pretty
hardcore sex scene
watching a sex scene like that on imax
it's like whoa
eva green's boobs are really in my face
right now
at one point i just reached out my hand
to grab them i ended up grabbing zack
snyder's balls instead
which was just as cool like when they're
having sex it's not like 300 where it's
just like slow motion of
and this one is like yeah you [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's the kind of sex it feels
like
hitting each other and one body just
throws her on the table and he just
starts
doing her from behind i kind of liked it
if that [ __ ] was on my favorite website
pornhub.com i would totally jerk off to
that now the guy plays xerxes in the
beginning of the film it was cool
because i was like oh you see xerxes
he's just a regular dude at one point
his dad dies and then he
he decides like oh i need to become like
[ __ ] evil god and so he takes a dip
in the pool and suddenly he comes out
looking like
well the bald drag queen you know just
surrender to me all i ask
is that you kneel that's all the guy
ever wants from people he's giving [ __ ]
about what people do as long as they
kneel he's a happy camper but
the weird thing is like you kind of
forget about him through most of the
film like there's really not much focus
on him and i thought there'd be a lot of
it because it said it's based on a comic
called xerxes but his role feels kind of
diminished uh eva green
is just way more interesting to watch
and takes up a lot more screen time yeah
i totally
have that kind of sex with her i hope
she likes having sex the way she does in
that movie
in real life i love her to punch me
right on my teeth
and then decapitate me so yes there's
more story there's more character
development
some of it people are gonna love some
might not like it so much
the main thing is there's [ __ ]
dynamic awesome action and some of the
best visuals you'll ever see in the
cinema and eva green
steals the show let me get straight to
the point here all in all i gotta say
300 rise of an empire got it right
thanks for checking out my review for
300 rise of an empire why don't you go
ahead
scroll that comment box below and tell
me who do you think has a bad ass and if
you want to see more episodes of
straight to the point
i'm trying to overcome that motorcycle
sound outside and last but not least if
you want to get updated every time one
of my reviews or videos is out going to
clear this bottom of my dick to
subscribe
that's right the dick
let me tell you something about this
little spartan he has boned
all kinds of chicks and guess how many i
i bet you won't be able to guess the
number it's
it's the number you won't expect coming
it's 300 it's 300.
no it's okay guys
it's just my penis that's boned a lot of
girls
you